- Big industrial inventions
in the 21st century
are made by research and development teams
at enormous corporations.
They don't come out of
somewhere like this,
a traditional workshop and foundry
that can still be powered by steam
sitting in a rural town in Australia.
And yet.
A screw is a very simple machine,
it takes rotational motion and
turns it into linear motion
so you can rotate this screw,
the stuff down there will get picked up,
and friction will stop it
falling down again right away.
That's called a vertical screw conveyor.
And you'll find something
like this in factories around the world
for lifting and moving bulk
powder or grain or sand.
What would happen if instead
of rotating the screw,
you instead kept it still
and just rotated this cylinder around it?
My guess when someone showed me this was, well, nothing.
The cylinder will just rotate in place,
it's just a cylinder with a
couple of scoops at the bottom.
If you're confused by that, so was I.
- The Olds name came from Cornwall.
My grandfather came out in
1868, at 18 years of age.
Dad made his first engine,
a steam engine, in 1906 when he was 16.
And 1925, my older brother was born,
he's still going,
and [laughs] I came along in 1930.
We served an apprenticeship
under our father, unofficially,
from when we were kids.
We try to keep up with the
times as much as we can,
but using traditional methods.
Just before Christmas, I think 2003,
we had this new mixer that we'd bought.
It was 20-odd thousand dollars
and we had it set up where
we were going to use it.
Nothing seemed suitable for
the elevation of the sand
up to the hopper over the top,
over the machine,
and I woke one morning,
three o'clock in the morning,
with this crazy idea
and made a sketch of it
and went back to bed and went to sleep.
And the next day I came to work
and I said, I had a
thought about making this.
Nah, that won't work, they said
and I said well, we're going to try it.
It was only a matter of days or a week
and we had the first
little machine operating.
We drove it with an
electric drill. We set about
making a decent machine then
and we put it in the foundry.
It did the job amazing. People were
coming to have a look at it
and I realised we should put a
patent application in on it.
This was so different I thought
it'd be easily protected.
Because rotating the
casing instead of the screw
you can see that it's different.
We spent a lot of money
on patent coverage.
And the name Olds Elevator
had been applied to it.
And they're made in America and Holland
and France and Spain.
[laughs] You name it.
With this elevator, it's a full flow.
And there's no movement of air, virtually,
except what might be between
the particles of sand.
So there's really no dust
generated by the machine.
Only where it falls back
through the open air.
This is also a very important thing
where you're handling
dusty explosive materials.
Corn dust is highly explosive.
Sugar. Big explosion
in the USA a few years back
and it demolished a refinery.
The clearance between
the inside of the rotating
tube and the screw
allows product to go through it
and not be damaged, not crushed.
It's a very forgiving type of machine
because it can be in very poor condition
and it'll work.
It's been found that it's a
more accurate volumetric feeder than
a lot of the devices that are being used.
- This took a while to get my head around.
Visually, rotating the cylinder
instead of the screw, is very different.
But from a physics
perspective, it's really not.
If you rotate the screw, it
looks like each level in there
is moving upwards, but
that's just an illusion.
It's just rotating horizontally.
Stuff gets lifted because
as the screw rotates
the particles at the top of the pile
are shoved out of the way and they prefer
to take the easy route
upwards through air,
instead of pushing the heavy
bulk below out of the way.
When you rotate the cylinder,
exactly the same thing is happening.
The buckets underneath force
the particles to go somewhere.
And when they're pushed into the screw,
they take the easy route up through air.
And the next ones do the same
and the next one, and the
next one, and the next one,
and everything keeps going up.
They're taking the easy path.
It is counterintuitive.
And look, I am trying to
not make this be an infomercial.
I checked, and yeah, this is being used
all over the world now,
from food handling to solar power towers.
This is a good new way
of lifting bulk stuff.
So what
I really don't understand is,
through the 20th century, a century of
industrialization and automation,
how did no one spot this earlier?
- I don't know why somebody
else hasn't thought of it.
In the USA, they were calling me
Archimedes II. [laughs]
It's different, it's useful, and
if it helps people, well that's great.
- Thank you to Peter Olds and all the team
at Olds Engineering. You
can find out more about them
and about the Olds Elevator at
the link in the description.
I am going
to have to give you a hand
clearing up this bird seed. [laughs]